adventure mode is the perfect
alternative to fighting against other
players while still honing your skills
and progressing your dragons in
adventure mode you'll be placed in a
world rife with danger and you'll be
sent to perform a large number of quests
as you progress through a larger
single-player story similar to those of
a fully fledged RPG you'll encounter
various characters enemies and
environments as you make your way
through each act unraveling the deeper
story and lore behind dragons and
tightness as you embark on your
single-player missions you will be able
to earn great rewards complete missions
find hidden treasure and earn dragons
for completing each act there are 10
stages to enact with 15 exciting and
challenging missions in each stage each
mission rewards you with the star
collect 75 stars to unlock the tier 2
version of the dragon and all 150 stars
for the powerful tier 3 dragon the great
wars have been fought yet trouble
remains in the lands below and this is
where you are needed in adventure mode
when you're not fighting great battles
above act one sets the stage with the
elder of north being kidnapped and
darkness looming over the borders of the
vast mire bog deep within the forests an
illness corrupts the great guardian
trees without the guidance of the elder
and under constant siege the villagers
of the once peaceful mire bog have
fallen to despair take to the skies
Dragon Lord and head into the adventure
mode to explore the world of dragons and
Titans help the NOx wings to reclaim
their freedom and gain a new NOx wing
mount to fly into battle don't just
imagine the story play in act 2 has
players traveling deep into the mage key
to determine the source of the growing
evil presence in the lands the mage
chief has long been the pillar of
magical stability within the world but
has lately been the source of rumors and
whispers about what lies within these
ancient walls
work with the mighty soul rain dragons
and earn the right to ride this feared
dragon act three takes place in the
island empire home to some of the most
feared and respected warriors years of
internal strife have left the island
prone for a hostile takeover with each
passing second the dark forces grow
stronger and the remaining allies grow
weaker head to the island Empire now and
reclaim the lands for you and your
allies free the famed Quetzalcoatl from
pirate control and score one of the
legendary dragons for your own act for
the Titans hand is now in development
and will offer more exciting new
missions and adventures be sure to check
us out at Dragons and Titans comm and
like us on Facebook to stay up to date
on the game